The podcast host Joe Rogan is
now facing criticism
after he pushed
the anti-Semitic trope
that Jewish people are,
quote, into money.
Here's what he said.
Ilhan Omar, where she's
she's apologizing
for talking about
it's all about the Benjamins. Ye
Which is just about money.
She's talking about
shouldn't have apologized
to some anti-Semitic statement.
I don't think that is
it's about Benjamins or money.
You know,
the idea that Jewish people are
not into money is ridiculous.
Listen, it's like saying
Italians aren't into pizza.
It's stupid.
China's media analyst and access
media reporter
Sarah Fisher is joining us now.
Sarah, I mean,
what are people saying about tha
People are outraged.
But at this point,
people are kind of getting used
being a pattern with Joe Rogan.
This isn't the first time
that he's defended people who've
anti-Semitic remarks.
Obviously, he's
now coming out and making them.
I think people are frustrated
that Spotify hasn't said anythin
But historically,
they take their time
to respond to these things.
But you talk to Daniel Ek,
who is the CEO of Spotify, about
What do you say?
Not about this specifically,
but if there are issues, bigger
Sure.
This is something that Spotify
has been talking about for a lon
How do they think about
content moderation?
Because they're not the same
as Google and Facebook.
There are different
kind of platform ultimately.
Obviously, they'll say
that they care a lot about safet
But remember, they're a Swedish
so they think about these things
and how they play out in the US
a little bit differently.
The one thing that distinguishes
Spotify and Daniel from other te
is they take their time.
You're not going to see some sor
of rushed policy implemented tod
They'll probably come out and co
these remarks.
Maybe they'll throw
a misinformation label
and then presumably everything
will just move on.
I'm not saying that
that's what it should be,
but that's what's happened in th
With Joe Rogan. Yeah.
Talk a little bit
just quickly about that,
because you said they'll just pu
a label on it.
That's what happens,
like these streaming sites now
where, you know
they have to pay for the site.
There's sort of the Wild, Wild W
where you can say what you want.
There are no standards and pract
and really
you don't have to answer to anyo
So basically,
this probably will not hurt
Joe Rogan
and everyone will
just sort of move on from.
It's definitely not going to hur
Joe Rogan.
It's not going to hurt Spotify.
They do have some policies,
but you're right.
Streaming is the wild, wild
west of content moderation